Welcome to the presentation
on i and imaginary numbers.
So let me just start
out with a definition.
i is equal to the square
root of negative 1.
Or to view it another way,
you could say that i squared
is equal to negative 1.
Now why is this special?
Well, we knew or we've learned
that any number when you
square it is equal to a
positive number, right?
If I had negative 1
times negative 1, that
equals positive 1.
You don't have to write the
positive every time but that
equal positive 1 and so
does 1 times 1, that
equals positive 1.
So if we think about the square
root of a number, so far all
we've learned is taking the
square roots of positive
numbers, and that makes sense
to us because the notion of a
square root of a negative
number didn't really
exist until now.
So what we've done is we've set
this definition that the number
i, and i isn't a variable,
it's an actual number.
It's value is equal to the
square root of negative 1.
Now I won't go into all of the
philosophical musings about
whether i, as a number i, or
any imaginary numbers
actually exist.
Maybe I'll make another
presentation on that.
But they exist enough to
be very useful to many
engineers and physicists.
So I'll leave you with that,
and I'll also just hint at --
well, I won't go into the
whole e to the i pi
equals negative 1.
But that blows my mind,
but I won't go into that.
And when you think about
whether i really exists, you
should also think about whether
anything really exists.
So, I've diversed for too long,
so let's get back to what I was
saying before. i is equal to
the square root of
negative 1, and i squared
equals negative 1.
So let's think about the
implications of this.
If I were to say -- well, i to
the first power, just like
anything else, is equal
to itself, right?
i squared, I've already said
using this definition, i
squared is equal to negative 1.
i to the third power, well
that would just equal i
squared times i, right?
And i squared is negative 1, so
it would be negative 1 times i.
And that just
equals negative i.
And i to the fourth would
equal i to the third times i.
I'm just using my
exponent rules here.
Well i to the third is negative
i times i, right? i to the
third is negative i, and
then we just kept that i.
Well what's negative i times i?
Well that's the same thing
as negative 1 times
i times i, right?
And what's i times i?
Well, the definition.
i times i, i squared, is
equal to negative 1.
So that equals negative 1 times
negative 1, which equals 1.
Interesting.
Let me clean this
up a little bit.
Actually let me start with
i to the zero power.
i to the zero power, well we
know anything to the zero
power is equal to 1.
So we'll keep that --
that still equals 1.
i to the first power
is equal to i.
i squared by definition
is equal to negative 1.
i to the third power, I just
showed you, is equal to
negative i, and that makes
sense because that's
just i squared times i.
And i to the fourth
power equaled 1 again.
If I did i to the fifth power,
well that's just equal to i to
the fourth power
times i, right?
I'll write that down, i
to the fourth times i.
i to the fourth is
equal to 1, right?
This is equal to 1, so 1
times i is equal to i.
Do you see a pattern here?
i to the zero power equals 1.
i to the negative
1 power equals i.
i squared is equal
to negative 1.
i to the third power
equals negative i.
i the fourth equals 1 again.
So i to the fourth equals i to
zero, and i to the one power
is equal to i to the fifth.
I think you'll find out that i
to the zero, and you could try
this out if you don't believe
me, i to the zero is equal to i
to the fourth, which equals i
to the eighth, which equals i
to the twelfth, I think
you see the pattern.
Any multiple of 4 equals 1.
And i to the first equals i to
the fifth, equals i to the
ninth equals i to the
thirteenth, equals i.
So that's i to any power
that is a multiple
of 4 plus 1, right?
Because 5 is equal to 4 plus
1, nine is equal to 8 plus 1.
And we could do a similar
pattern. i squared is equal to
i to the sixth, equals i to
the tenth, and so on, and
that equals negative 1.
And finally i to the third is
equal to i to the seventh,
which equals i to the eleventh,
and so on, equals negative i.
So why is this useful?
We see a pattern.
It's a cycle of four.
In this pattern, if we
look at this, we can use
this to determine what
i to any power is.
So if I were to ask you what i
to the hundredth power is,
well, you could just work it
out, you could say, well that's
just equal to i times i to the
ninety-ninth and
so far so down.
But if we use the cycle,
we see that hundred is
a multiple of 4, right?
4 times 25 is 100.
So i to the hundredth will
fall into this category,
this first one.
It's a multiple of 4.
So we know that i to the
hundredth power is equal to 1.
Similarly, if I said i to the
hundred and one power, that's
going to equal i, right?
Because that equals 100 plus 1.
So it puts you into
this category.
Equal to a multiple of 4, 100
is a multiple of 4, and 101
is a multiple of 4 plus 1.
i to the hundred and second
power, similarly would
equal negative 1.
i to the hundred and third
power would equal negative i.
I hope you understand what I'm
doing here, and all I did is I
defined i as the square root of
negative 1, and then I
kept multiplying i to
figure out a pattern.
I said i to the zero equals 1,
i to the first equals i, i
squared equals negative 1, i to
the third equals negative i,
and i to the fourth
equals 1 again.
And the pattern
repeated itself.
And then I used that pattern to
be able to figure out i to any
power, even it's a
very high number.
So a very simple way to think
about it is if I had i to the
three hundred and twenty three.
What I do is I say if I
were to divide 4 into 323,
what's the remainder?
Well, I know 4 goes
into 320, right?
4 times 80 is 320.
So I know that when I divide 4
into 323, so 4 goes into 323 80
times with a remainder
of 3, right?
And the remainder is
what we care about.
And this number is actually
called a modulus.
Maybe I'll do another module on
modulus -- it's very important
actually in computer
programming.
But since we know that when you
divide this exponent by 4 the
remainder is 3, we can say that
this is the same thing as i to
the third, which we've
learned is negative i.
Similarly, if I said i to
the five hundred and second
power, well I know 500 is
divisible by 4, right?
4 times 125 is 500.
So the remainder is 2 if
I were divide it by 4.
So I could say that this is
the same thing as i squared.
And i squared we learned by
definition is negative 1.
If I were to ask you i
to the thirty-seven?
We know 36 was divisible by
4, so the remainder is 1.
So it would be i to the
1, which equals i.
Hopefully that gives you an
indication of what i is.
It might have been confusing
the first time because we're
dealing with a number that's
"imaginary," and I'm teaching
the cycle property of it.
What you might want to do is
review the video again, but
then after that you could just
try the module on i, which
essentially just keeps working
you through this
type of problem.
I hope you have fun.
Bye.